hey guys sorry if I woke you up I know
it's late I haven't really done one of
these late-night vlogs in a long time I
don't know what the title says probably
something depressing honestly I'm not
I'm not depressed if it sounds like that
or whatever it is or whatever this boils
down to in a three word phrase I don't
know I as as usual when I do these lane
eye vlogs usually the fuel is me getting
nostalgic and she's no different I was I
was looking through deviantART and I was
looking at old pieces of fan art and I
was i I was remembering I was
remembering what was going on in those
times and I was taken back to those
moments in my life and I was taken back
to you know when I was first starting
the channel and and and one of the key
differences between then and now besides
the number of people here is it's not my
attitude towards making videos it's it's
my perspective from making videos
because before like I was beaming and
shining with optimism and I was looking
up you know looking up and I was looking
up at what could be and I had
aspirations and I had goals and I had I
had dreams and I had you guys and and
and it was like you know it was an
underdog story at that point and you
know I I I miss it like I really missed
that cuz you know you spend so so much
time looking at the top of the hill you
don't think what you couldn't do when
you get there and Here I am now with
almost 17 million people about to
subscribe and I'm trying to comprehend
what that means
cuz I had uh I almost don't feel like
I'm looking up anymore you know there
are certain realities about this job
that we're in a parent you know when I
was starting out and some of the harder
realities are you can't be there for
everybody and that that's the hardest
blow to take first when you realize that
the personal connection that you had
with your fans isn't as concrete as it
could be and you get stuck in this weird
loop where if you can't please everybody
then you have a tough time pleasing
anybody not exactly hi I only do videos
to please you guys but you know it's the
it's the conundrum of choice the more
choice you have the less happy you are
because you're not able to commit your
time to something and again I'm not
saying like I'm not trying to say I'm
depressed here I'm not actually I am
actually I'm happier than I have been
making videos but the one part where I'm
not as happy and it's becoming more
apparent the more dedicated I am back
into making videos and what happens is
and let me just give you a snippet of
what my life is right now
how how how [ __ ] up it's become since
I was in engineering school aspiring to
do YouTube videos in my bedroom to now
where I'm actively turning down movies
and TV roles and book deals and like I'm
saying no to all these things just cause
like I didn't come for that you know I I
don't know I feel like I feel like I
don't deserve it you know in a way like
I haven't earned it yet and
it and I feel like and I feel like in
that cuz what what it's the it's the
whole choice thing you know I've got so
many options that I can do and I've got
so many ambitions of what I want to do
it's not like I don't have goals but
there's so many things that I could
focus my time on that you end up
focusing on nothing and he end up just
kind of drifting but you're like I can't
give everything my undivided attention
so what would even be the point of like
commit starting now and then you just
end up in limbo and I know it might seem
like I'm whining here Oh
success it sucks so much nah that's not
what I'm saying because like me doing
this has never been about me being
successful it's been about you know this
amazing journey that I've been able to
be a part of and the amazing people that
I've met along the way and the
opportunities that have been given to me
I'm a mess sorry I don't know I just
feel lost like I feel like I'm aimlessly
wandering and I'm tired of it like I'm
tired of that feeling I'm tired of that
feeling of you know just staying in
limbo I'm tired of seeming like I'm not
going anywhere spinning my wheels cuz in
in the beginning after just Channel like
I didn't give a [ __ ] about the rules I
didn't give a [ __ ] about how people
fought YouTube videos should be done it
guided what am I trying to say I was
doing Let's Plays but you know I was
doing vlogs so I'm just two three times
a week just cuz I wanted to talk to you
guys I couldn't get enough of it like I
could not get enough of it I couldn't
stop talking to you guys and I couldn't
I couldn't give up on and I could never
give up on it and and then feeling like
that feeling I'm an introvert and and
and even I that feeling
the feeling of knowing that what you say
influences people and that feeling of
knowing that each and every one of those
people matter and their feeling of just
raw creation and the feeling of raw
unexplored territory and knowing that
like you don't know what's around the
corner like that feeling and I'm afraid
you know I'm afraid I'm afraid that
might actually that I've been doing this
for so long that I've lost even the
possibility of feeling that again like
that's my biggest fear that's always
been my biggest fears is losing my way
on YouTube I mean I could but I don't
care if my channel crashes and burns I
don't I don't care about that I don't
care if I fade into darkness like I
don't care I don't care if people hate
my my stuff my content I don't care if
people don't like my videos I've never
cared about that like I'm not afraid of
failure I'm afraid of disappointing you
guys like you are the most important
thing that's ever happened in my life
whether you know it or not because the
most amazing thing isn't isn't that I've
helped people or that I've you know
saved lives people say that all the time
I still doubt it but the most amazing
thing isn't that it's that you guys
saved me
hidden
I just want you guys to know and I want
you guys to know who I am the only way
cuz I can do that is by being more
honest both to myself and you guys and
I'm a goddamn disgusting mess and I know
it's horrible I know oh I know it's bad
but it's the truth it's the truth of who
I am it is the truth of where I've come
from it's the truth of where I I'm gonna
go if if I want to be where I want to be
I have to take the right steps and I
have to make the right choices I have to
make a conscious effort every day to be
better not just a drifting blase oh do
my videos every day because I'm
obligated to do that no and I'm not
saying I'm not gonna do my videos don't
get scared about that I'm not quitting
YouTube that's not what this video is
about I'm not doing that that's no not
at all
even it if it may sound like that no god
no I'm not quitting
god no I'm not quitting cuz I I couldn't
give up I'm not gonna give up like again
I at the beginning of this video I said
I'm not depressed and that's 100% true
I'm not I'm happier than I've ever been
and creatively like making cool things
I'm just remembering how important it
was to come across as who I really am
love the things that I really do and I
feel like I haven't been able to show
you guys are things that I love because
the only thing I love is the thing that
you guys make like god I love it
and I'm afraid you guys get sick of it
because I'm not really a fan of like
music and I'm not really a fan of other
things like I love space and all that
but if you were to summarize the list of
things I
it connected chika my girlfriend
space-like my family my friend and then
yeah like what I don't I don't listen
the music I drive with silence not a fan
of anything me you guys nothing's better
than seeing the amazing things that you
guys can make and seeing you grow and
seeing you go on and make your own
things and seeing what you can do it
it's amazing I love it I love it so much
and that's the feeling that's the
feeling I missed showing that just pure
and simple adoration of what you guys do
for me it's not like I'm saying worship
me as an idol make more fan art no I'm
not even saying about the stuff you make
for me like just the stuff that you guys
do it it's amazing he's unbelievably
amazing and I never want to lose that
feeling I gotta make sure that every day
every single day I chase that feeling
that's what drives me fat above all else
making cool [ __ ] is fine but that
actually gets bad in the morning that's
what makes me pull an all-nighter that
admit this what makes me want to be
better that's what makes me want to show
you guys what I can do
that feeling is everything anyway I
thought I was I thought I was done
blubbering but had a little more
blubbering me by Ivan Gaul into here
it's been rambling enough and you guys
got to get back to bed
sorry again for waking you or if you're
watching this in the middle of the day
and you have no idea what I'm talking
about just put it in the column where
I'm rambling
put it over there and yeah that's gross
I'm gonna keep talking to you guys more
and I'm gonna be here for you guys more
and again I'm not making empty promises
I won't do that
I've never do that again but it will be
better thank you everybody so much for
watching thanks for giving me some of
your time tonight and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye